hello everyone and welcome to a super
enjoyable and super complicated game uh
from round seven of the 2022 tata still
chess tournament it's pragananda versus
magnus carlsen and like i said this is
an extremely complicated game if you are
not well rested maybe save it for later
as there is quite a lot to cover uh but
before we dive into the game i would uh
just like to very briefly address what
happened in the game anish geary versus
daniel dubo as you know uh dubai
uh forfeited the game uh no moves were
played in that game uh and here is the
official statement uh from the tata
steel account uh daniel dubov will not
be playing in the seventh round of the
tata still chess tournament today uh due
to a covet 19 contamination in his inner
circle the tournament organization after
consultation with the chief arbiter has
asked adubov to play wearing a face mask
in order to protect his opponent
anishigiri dubo did not show for his
match which means that he has lost his
game by forfeit adobo has indicated that
he refuses to play wearing a face mask
as a matter of principle dubo himself
tested negative in a quick uh scan test
he uh he has also undergone a pcr test
of which the result is likely to come in
this evening so after the
games for today have uh have already
ended so yeah just in case you guys were
wondering what happened there now
getting back to this game prague with
the white pieces opens with d4 yeah we
have d5 by magnus c4 we have e6 in the
knight to f3 and now if you were
expecting another one uh of the of the
queen gambit declines or something like
that nope it's d captures on c for here
magnus accepts the queen's gambit and
goes for this very very uh well rarish
rosenthal variation of the queen's
gambit accepted
prague addresses this very principally
he plays e3 goes after the c4 pawn and
now just um a6 by magnus so we've seen a
lot of catalans being played where black
actually defends the pawn with b5 but
here it's not so easy uh here white can
just attack the pawn chain and let's say
black defense we can capture captures
captures b3 and you have some problems
here you you can't defend everything
you're going to have to capture and
after queen captures or even better
bishop captures and b5 with check you're
going to block this queen captures on b3
white is developing very very nicely
that a pawn will be weak and well it's
just a much better position for white so
that's why in these structures the pawn
is not guarded so here we play a6 you
offer the c4 pawn but then you will have
a tempo at some point with b5 so bishop
captures on c4 knight to f6 and here
prague castles we have c5 by magnus and
now b3 preparing bishop to a3 to hinder
black's development or rather castling
b6 and now bishop to a3 we have knight
beat to d7 by magnus and now as the
queen no longer guards the d5 square uh
prague takes this opportunity to advance
the pawn all the way to d5 so we have e
captures bishop captures now attacking
the rook and the position has been
reached before in two games in the
database and uh or knight captures on d5
was played in all of the games uh
resulting in something like knight
captures queen captures uh the rook is
attacked after rook to b8 we're gonna
move the bishop back bishop to b2 and
after something like bishop to e7 uh or
rather you will not be able to castle if
if bishop to e7 white can capture on g7
so it's a really tricky position but
black might even consider this and go
for some sort of an aggressive line but
magnus not uh
feeling um
that uh well uh that uh giving this game
uh he he is on a quest to reach 2900 um
classical elo he just continues with
rook to b8 and it is now as of move 10
that we have a completely new game so
let's see how prague continues we have
bishop back to b2 uh and now bishop to
e7 magnus is ready to castle we have
knight c3 both players just continue
development and queen c2 developing the
queen connecting the rooks and now b5 so
a very nice expansion on the queen side
by magnus we have rook f the d1 aligning
the rook with the queen and of course
queen to c7 developing while
sidestepping the d file uh and now
prague goes for a4 uh challenging this
advanced structure on the queen side i
will however mention there is a very
tricky knight to the g5 line but um uh
well
if played perfectly it only yields the
draw point is that there's a lot of
stuff here aiming at carlson's king as
you can see both of the bishops the the
queen and usually there's always
something there and just to give you an
example for example h6 we're going to
play bishop captures on f7 and after
rook captures there's this knight to d5
idea very tricky where you can't capture
the knight because if you capture the
knight queen h7 checking if eight queen
to h8 is checkmate so the knight cannot
be captured you're gonna have to move
the queen and now we're just gonna play
bishop captures on f6 so we want to
remove everything uh from defending h7
and after knight captures just knight
captures on f6 and now you can't capture
with the bishop or the rook because
queen to h7 so you're going to have to
capture with the g pawn and now we
finally play knight captures on f7 and
the black king cannot capture the knight
uh due to queen to h7
with some problems for black so you're
gonna have to just move the king and uh
well continue playing this game take
away the g6 square from the white queen
and it's really really complicated but
um all in all uh both players are
perfectly fine here so just wanted to
mention that it is in the position uh
however extremely complicated so prague
advances the pawn on the queen side he
plays ponte a4 and now we have h6 by
magnus magnus uh senses that there could
be some trouble here with this knight to
g5 idea so he addresses it even though
uh b4 is also is also possible uh for
example b4 knight to e2 and now we trade
on d5 and knight captures rook captures
and now c4
is very nice it's a it's a pawn uh but
we play b3 we already have a pass pawn
on b3 so that could be could be very
strong uh but okay magnus sends that
there is some danger here he played h6
and now we have a capture sun b5 a
captures and queen to e2 going after
that b5 pawn so magnus defends it we
have queen to b6 and now e4 uh so both
players are playing very nicely we have
rook to e8 developing the rook and queen
to d2 now
we have bishop to f8 uh very useful the
bishop here will be a nice defender of
black's king side this bishop is a
monster here so we need to address this
and also this opens up the rook to
uh use the
uh use the usd file uh so here uh prague
needs to figure out how how to continue
this you could play some like rook to e1
add another uh defender here also might
have some ideas of pushing the pawn but
probably played queen to f4 and it comes
with the idea of maybe trying to
overload the knight here because if the
position opens up the rook and uh on v8
could be hanging and uh
so it could be tricky carlson's rooks
are not connected so here magnus goes
pawn to b4 uh he uses the oddly placed
queen and f4 to his advantage because
now uh prague plays knight to a4 but
also bishop captures an f7 is always an
idea for for example bishop captures
king captures knight d5 attacks the
queen and of course the knight cannot
move because the king is now uh on f7 so
queen to e6 now we're going to play
knight captures and now uh again the
knight cannot capture because the rook
hangs hence the placement of the queen
on f4 and after g captures it's a very
very difficult position for example rook
a7 and i don't know uh pretty pretty
crazy stuff king j8 on pinning and uh
well it looks like anything can happen
but all in all with precise calculation
black should be okay here so
uh prague decides against this he plays
knight to the a4 attacks the queen
and now magnus just plays knight
captures on d5 he's very happy with the
queen trade here prague decides against
it he plays the rook captures on d5 and
now the position is as it is a little
bit better for magnus because the knight
here is uh pretty bad and c4 will uh
make this knight even weaker and then
you're probably not going to be able to
capture then c3 is coming and so on and
the situation on the clock is this is
only moved 21 15 minutes for prague and
22 minutes for magnus and here we have
queen to e6 uh here you could also play
queen to c6 kind of guarding that uh c5
pawn but magnus decides for a different
idea he plays queen to e6 and this
allows um uh prague to sort of equalize
with knight captures on c5 but he misses
the idea uh for example bishop captures
rook captures and c5 now if the knight
captures then we pick up the rook but
there really isn't anything better so
knight captures queen captures and now
queen captures on b3 this is the
position you get uh but again with a
very little time on the clock the
material is equal magnus has a past b
pawn so it would be magnus who will be
pushing for for a win here but okay
after queen e6 uh prague played rook a
to d1 he doubled on the d file and it
makes sense you want to remove that
defender off of the rook here but still
even if you capture this bishop captures
then this regards the rook here
it's very very unclear however he allows
magnus a certain idea uh
or rather a series of ideas that allows
uh him to take a winning advantage in
this position
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this idea for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this it
pretty much
incorporates everything that we've
discussed so far and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
either c4 or rook to a8 both of those
moves will be played so uh it's uh it's
really a matter of preference however
magnus played rook to a8 so
congratulations to everyone who found
that but also c4 is the first line of
the suku of the norwegian super computer
sese so i will show that just for fun so
the idea is c4 and now the problem is if
you play b captures on c4 then rook to
a8 kind of combining the idea with what
magnus played the knight here is hanging
and you don't really have a square for
this knight all of the squares are taken
so you have to defend it and now you
play bishop b7 you attack the rook and
once the rook moves now you play bishop
captures on e4 and this is now a
well a terrible terrible position for
for white and not going to be uh
possible to get to get out of this one
so instead after c4 you're gonna play
have to play something else for example
knight to e5 but then we play knight
captures on e5 bishop captures on e5 and
now rook to a8 again putting pressure on
the knight so this is impossible uh
we're gonna play knight c5 attack the
queen now queen g4 we offer a queen
trade where white either trades or play
something like f3 forces the trade on f4
captures captures and now black will get
the c3 move and this is now again a
winning position for black so not easy
to see and well especially to decide
that it's actually winning but uh you
know if a supercomputer says it is and
the magnus agrees with it then it
definitely is so magnus starts with rook
to a8 instead he's preparing c4 uh but
now uh prague has uh well he he has to
figure out how to try and get out of
this both players are very low on time
so he can at least complicate matters
and uh
he starts by playing queen back to c1 so
keeping an eye on that c for square but
also just giving up the e4 pawn you
could never defend this pawn because
black can always just add more attackers
and you're going to lose it um anyway so
queen captures on e4 and now uh what do
you play here well again very very long
time prague plays h3 because there are a
lot of back rank issues here look at all
of this pressure on the
on the back rank you have to play h3 at
some point uh just to give you an
example for example rook captures on d7
okay we could give up the rook for uh
for two pieces uh but now rook d8 and
let's say captures captures again uh
queen to e2 followed by rook to d1 is
just crushing so you have to play h3 now
we're still gonna play queen to e2 for
example queen e3 and now queen to d1
check and now again look at this the
queen again eyeing this knight here
after king to h2 we're going to play c4
and again we get our c3 move uh white
cannot capture because the knight hangs
and that's pretty much it
you play bishop d4 so the bishop doesn't
get locked c3 and again black with a
winning advantage uh so not not possible
although i know you guys were wondering
about that so h3 was played but now
magnus just placed rook to a7 adding
more defense here to the knight we have
queen to d2 prague a very very devious
idea trying to trick magnus to play c
for now because if c for now then prague
plays rook to e1 and wins uh magnus just
loses a rook on e8 so magnus spots this
he sidesteps it with queen to g6 we have
knight to h4 attacking the queen and
queen back to e6 so again uh not not
easy for prague to play this we have
knight to f5 uh like i said it's not
easy but prague keeps finding ways of
how to how to deal with the position and
he's getting a very active position he
has a rook queen rook battery and the
default he has a very active knight on
f5 the bishop
attacking the king's side and it's uh
well
very very uh
tricky position uh with both players
only one minute on the clock and still
they have to make 12 more moves to reach
time control uh so here magnus uh played
c4 but the real beauty was bishop to b7
this kind of
allows everything that prague planned
and that is knight captures an h6 check
so we're just gonna show it queen
captures an h6 check queen captures an
h6 check and now probably why magnus
hasn't played it because they were very
much low on time now of course you don't
capture the queen you play bishop
captures on d5 so you have to sacrifice
the queen with black and now white's
queen is hanging once white moves it now
we play bishop captures on b3 attack the
knight and the rook and after rook d3
trying to well go for rook to g3 to put
more pressure on g7 uh we're going to
play bishop to c2 attack the rook once
rook goes to g3 we can now either block
with bishop to g6 or even rook to a6 so
we allow white to capture on g7
and after this is played we play rook to
g6 attack the queen after queen d2 now
we just trade everything off rook
captures f captures bishop captures on
a4 bishop captures on f8 king captures
and you get this position where magnus
has a rook and two pieces plus two past
pawns against prague's queen and of
course this is completely winning for
black uh so i i i i hope you guys uh
didn't think i was joking when i said
this game was super complicated uh but
okay magnus played c4 he misses the
queen sacrifice there
and now prague again has one opportunity
to to try and uh
fight this uh but he has to find it and
of course c3 is coming so you have to
react to this best way is to react with
bishop captures on g7 it was not played
in the game that point is that after
bishop captures knight captures with a
fork uh king captures now comes rook to
d6 connecting with the h6 pawn and after
queen to e7 now we play queen captures
an h6 king g8 and rook to d4 with some
nasty ideas of trying to checkmate the
black king but unfortunately for white
none of it works for example knight to
f8 you don't have a good move you don't
have rook g4 the bishop covers this this
square so you're just going to have to
play rook captures on c4 if you try
something like rook to h4 we don't
really care just a queen to e1 check
king h2 and the queen to e5 now guards
everything the queen guards h8 the
knight covers h7
and that's pretty much it g3 queen to g7
black defense and black will uh win the
game but it was the uh the best fighting
chance uh if you play it properly here
with rook captures on c4 black would
still have to struggle very much for the
win uh with a minute on the clock
however prague played queen to d4 he had
to figure out a quick way to
prevent c3 from losing the game but now
magnus just plays in knight to f6 and
now pretty much all of the threats here
are gone knight to b6 now uh getting
that knight out of the way so now
finally threatening to capture here but
now magnus finally advances the pawn
pawn to c3 and a capture fest now starts
knight captures on c8 we have queen
captures on d5
queen captures on the e5 knight captures
on the e5 and the knight captures on a7
and finally c captures on b2 so the
material is sort of equal magnus is only
up one pawn but that past b pawn is
unstoppable prague played rook to b1 but
now magnus just played rook to e2 and he
was in this position on move 34 that
pragananda resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here there is
absolutely no defense against knight to
c3 whatever you play king f1 you attack
the rook just knight c3 defends the rook
threatens the rook on b1 and you're
gonna have to capture to prevent uh
black getting a queen and now white will
just be down a whole rook
so really an incredible game both
players played very very creatively and
even after they they were on their own
uh such incredible moves were played by
both of them prague almost saved the
game he almost got out of it but he
missed uh
some very very tricky lines but with a
minute on the clock so no one can uh
blame him for that really
but uh yeah very nice game a second win
for magnus in row and this also means
that magnus is now in seoul lead with
five points out of seven uh and what
does this mean for his uh actual quest
uh because his actual quest isn't
winning the tata still it's actually
reaching 2900 elo
in classical chess so far in the
tournament even though he's five out of
seven he only gained one elo point
that's uh how how a severe magnus has to
be winning in order to actually gain
points so we'll see if the winning
streak continues or will he again uh you
know suffer some draws or maybe even a
loss uh there are still uh plenty of
rounds to go
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it sorry for all the variations
but i mean they were super enjoyable so
hope you enjoyed them as well
i would like to thank mahali havahan ron
swanson thomas earl carly simmer and
david kimura for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this uh uh
amazing tournament uh until it ends uh
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day